[Musique]
qu'est bien Victor
madame nous sommes moy oui de chose nous
s pas une cloison c'est tout je souhaite
bonne nuit à mêtes pas trop fatigé je
suis raté mon P là je vais me coucher
dans 2 minutes avec un bon somnif oh
tant mieux je vous souite une bonne nuit
madame j'espère que vous NZ pas sortir n
avons une longue route je vous en forme
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que va imagin je
n'imagine rien mais nous sommes à Las
Vegas les boîtes de nuit les machines à
sous il y a des tentations pour un grand
je ah oui mais il en faut plus que ça
pour me tenter vous
saz de sommeil arrêtez vous me faites
bailler et bien dans quel état nous
sommes oui nous ne sommes pas du jour
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire je vous
souhaite une bonne nuit
[Musique]
bonsoir
vous êtes là vous sortez pas du tout oh
pas du tout alors qu'est-ce qui peut
laisser supposer une chose pareille à
Madame c'est pas cette tenue c'est ma
c'est c'est mon pyjama du soir ah c'est
très très chic oui et le nœud papillon
je suis fragile de la gorge je suis très
aux engin alors la nuit j'aime bien
mettre ça je trouve que c'est plus
élégant qu'une petite laine oui c'est
très bien c'est joli voilà mais vous
même madame deviez faire attention parce
que je trouve que chemise de nuit un peu
décoleté oui je vous vois vous allez me
dire elle ressemble à une robe du soir
oh pas du tout madame je pasmis c'est
nouveau c'est nouveau c'est fait exprès
comme ça dès qu'on dès qu'on se lève
n'est-ce pas dès qu'on sort du lit on
est tout de suite habillé bah c'est bien
c'est pratique c'est très
bien qu'est-ce que vous faites dans le
couloir en pyjama du soir et bien
qu'est-ce que je fais ah oui ah bah si
j'étais venu pour retourner ma petite
pancarte don ne te disturbe ne pas
déranger j'ai horreur d'ê dérangé le
matin par la femme de ménage qui veut
absolument faire votre lit quand vous
êtes dedans en train de dormiragréable
je vais vous faire rire j'avais eu la
même idée je me suis dit tiens ma petite
cocotte si tu sortais furtivement pour
retourner ta petite
pancarte je vais la retourner pour ça
oui par que vous êtes là maintenant ce
sera de pas en profiter je souhaite une
bonne nuit à
Madame
[Musique]
allô allô allô c'est Madame oh c'est
Victor c'est Victor madame mais que se
passe-t-il une pas du tout madame
j'avais le sentiment de vous avoir dit
bonsoir un peu sèchement je tenais à
m'en excuser parce que j'ai peur d'avoir
des REM ça m'empêche de dormir madame
mais quelle charmante pensée Victor je
vous en remercie beaucoup c'est tout
naturel c'est je vous laisse parce que
mon somnifère commence à faire un peu
d'ffit oui moi aussi j'ai som je
souhaite la bonne nuit bonsoir bonsoir
mer
beaucoup ça va faire du bien de se
coucher
dans
allô allô allô Victor allô Victor allô
Victor vous m'entendez c'est Madame oh
je vous demande pardon madame j'ai
oublié d'enlever mes boulesè écoutez je
voulais dire que votre coup de téléphone
tout à l'heure m'a touché infiniment je
voulais vous en remercier vivement mais
c'est tout naturel chame non c'était
très très très gentil j'en suis toute
bouleversé encore alors soyez gentil
remettez vos boules et dormez
tranquillement je vous remercie je
compte sur bonsoir madame bon au revoir
mon petit
[Musique]
Victor
c'est non si c'est c'est
vousoui vous savez j'étais sorti je me
suis dit tiens tu ma grande tu as oublié
de mettre tes chaussures dans le couloir
pour qu'on Lesire écoutez vous vous
allez rire parce que je viens porter les
mienes exactement pour la même chose oh
alors que c'est amusant on a on a des
choses qui n passent par la tête mais
les ves je me demande si c'est la peine
elle brille bien BR parce qu' un peu de
lumière mais dans le no plus du tout
mais vousmême Madame V très fragile le
STR très très fragile si on s pas le STR
tous les jours j on pe plus dans c'est
terrible très bien et bien écoutez voilà
al alors
on
bien
c'est Madame mon Dieu oh c'est Madame oh
que je suis content que ce soit madame
mon Dieu je me disais je me disais j'ai
dit au revoir à Madame tout à l'heure je
même pas serrer la main ça m dorm ça m'a
traumatisé heureusement c'est Madame si
ça avait été quelqu'un
d' c'est un réflexe nerveux on y pe bien
écoutz écoutez nous n'en sortirons
jamaisve j'ai peur j'ai peur qu'on nen
sorte pas alors je vais vous dire une
bonne chose puisque vous êtes en pyjama
du soir espoir et moi en chemise de nuit
on sa pas ce qu'on dit là et ben voilà
alors si nous passions la nuit
ensemble comment au cabaret ah avec ah
au C ah oui oh tout ce que tout ce que
j'aime madame tout ce que j'aime et ben
alors
allons-y c'est ah bah
c'est